[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs veuillez
accueillir votre maître de cérémonie
pour cette soirée des césar
monsieur manu payet
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir on saura tout pour sera tous et
quel honneur d'être ici devant vous ce
soir je suis particulièrement ému car
depuis que je suis petit je regarde
cette cérémonie
chaque année j'ouvrais les enveloppes
dans ma tête une à une
depuis mon canapé ça va être là toute la
soirée et j'ai vu tout le monde gagner
j'ai dû tout le monde pleurait
d'affronter les îles auquel on chialait
oies qui sait qui parle à plus tard la
toile et moi je suis maître de cérémonie
vous vous êtes qui les composent et
séléné sait jamais vous parlez alors
payet en hellénique est quand je te
reconnais tes meilleurs sons vous êtes
toujours 3es vos discours sont très
longs je voudrais remercier michel moi
aussi je voudrais remercier michel non
non non non non non renverser les michel
tout à l'heure et pas longtemps les
meilleurs remerciements
c'est ce qui dure le moins longtemps si
t'es pas tous les intermittents et on
s'en fout de vos parents tiens j'ai une
idée
on va faire une photo ok à moi la régie
hockey des jeux mais pas qu'on dit
d'elle moi non plus ah bah non plus c
est avec l âge n 3 n'ont pas moi au
meilleur actrice miley pêche quelqu'un
pour allumer ma cigarette
oui non merci je suis un grand fan mais
j'ai bien peur qu'il ne soit plus
possible de filmer du par mais alors
quoi vous allez demander un meilleur
actrice de 20 poté
oui mon ciré et raison des compensées cv
j en ai trop fait on sera tous sur
déchiré
par d'autres casser l'ambiance restait
très longtemps mais un montage vous est
reconnue vous avez pas commencer
maintenant
moi par exemple je couperai on comprend
très bien sans famille quatre personnes
[Musique]
c'est vachement bien meilleur second
rôle
et puis ça jamais été dit en plus et si
trouver quelque chose de nouveau un truc
- oui ce que je veux dire
cai merci oui meilleur acteur je suis là
je suis là deux secondes là je suis au
téléphone
ouais je sais pas ça part en comédie
musicale est tarifé genre on existons
mais vivant jamais rien dans ces visuels
ouais c'est sûr canal ouais ouais on est
en direct ça nous laisse un peu gérant
je suis meilleur acteur alors si j'ai
envie de passer un coup de fil je passe
en coup de fil d'accord mais si j'ai
envie de raccrocher je raccroche à léon
seront récompensés
[Musique]
y'en a pas le sujet en mer dont nobilise
césar du meilleur film étranger
bah oui mais ils viennent jamais vous
cherchez en même temps j'ai pas content
j'ai beau ton mouche
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut que tu par un
je suis passé d'être la sec ou bas super
émouvant
bah oui mais faut pas pleurer non mais
c'est parce que c'est meilleur espoir
féminin c'est sa première fois ici elle
est très émotive et vous êtes qui fut
meilleur espoir masculin des manu je
n'aime pas du tout petit face à d'accord
vous voulez quoi meilleure réalisatrice
je ne sais pas proposez moi quelque
chose des siciliens je dirais que c'est
mon idée action
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gsm désessard cela
et césar
[Applaudissements]
de la sorte après j je sors du katri 89
que m
gênant mais c'est qui alors on voulait
commencer la fête sans moi c'est le
meilleur film attendez je vais essayer
de lui parler en langage cinéma peut ppm
dire de prod2
je sais pas quoi lui dire vrai vu la
gueule de meilleurs films star ici
encore pas une comédie il manquerait
plus que ça on peut jamais rien lui dire
un meilleur film ao oui là le boulard
attends je vais le calme et moi mais au
meilleur film allait redescendre deux
secondes mon pote
parce que sans eux vous seriez retient
ici d'accord ouais alors vous mettez sur
la photo et vous arrêtez votre cinéma
[Musique]
je sais me rapprocher les qu'on fait ça
tous les jours
[Musique]
sur une sale année pourquoi pourquoi
s'il fallait raser chômage de 8 mille
ans peut-être élite où il perd des noms
mais ce sont de bons dommage ce sont de
beaux hommages on va tomber d'accord
qu'est ce qui nous empêche de rang ce
sakifo des soirs comme ça il y en a 4
par an
fait mon mieux et vous savez quoi puis
comme cent des billets
est ce qu'il faut faire dans toutes les
villes
on est cinéma français et l'anglais tous
ici ce soir
d'accord pour dire qu'on a tous temps
plein
à tout à l'heure les césar merci césar
[Applaudissements]